(slogans)
"Femme, vie, liberté".
Ces
dans les rues iraniennes,
alququque la révolte entame
son troisième mois et
(coups de feu)
Des coups de feu dans..........
(cris)
Une femme qui s'écroule
sous des coups de matraque :éfé.
(coups de feu)
Le régime riposte avec
encore plus de violence.
çaçaçaçaçaçaçaçaçaçaçaçaçaçaçaçs
sont désertes quand elles
ne sont pas prises d'assaut
par les manifestants.
Un peu partout en Iran,
l'heure est àpppppposition.
- We want a free country...
sans oppression et où les droits
de la personne sont respectés",
nous confie cette lycéenne
(coup de feu)
Car si des manifestants
tombent sous les balles,
HANIEH ZIAEI, politologue,
Ch R R Raoul-Dandurand de l'UQAM
- On connaît pas leurs
conditions carcérales, mais on a
eu viol? Certainement qu'il y a
b b brutalité, certainement
qu'il y a eu de la torture.
Et à la fois, vous avez de lavez
aussi la torture psychologique.
- Des sévices que la jeune Yalda
Aghazafli,enenenenenenenenenene.
Dimanche, elle est retrouvée
sans vie peu de temps après
sa libération.
PA
directeur de l'IRIS
- Dès qu'il y a un mort,
il y a un foyer de contestation
supplémentaire qui se crée.
était la révolte de femmes
éduquées dans les villes, est
devenue un mouvement à la fois
mixte, hom
- Cette étudiante nous avoue
que ueueue jour, elle brave
l'obligation de se voiler,
- On n'a pas encore vu,
je pense, tout le visagetetetet.
Le mouvement actuel a
une portée universelle qui
transcende les classes sociales,
Et c'est ça qui est intéressant.
(broa)a)a)
- On peut penser que le régime
est en train de jouer sa un lite
qui est de plus en plus fort.
Mais il n'y a pas de leader,
et donc, le régime espère
de la révolte.
(slogans)
- Pour l'instant, comme
le scandent ces jeunes,
le sang versé ne sera pas vain,
que le pouvoir sera renversé.
l'espérance et l'inquiétude,
trtrtre un régime extrêmement
conservateur et une jeunesse
ouverte sur le monde.
Radio-Canada, Montréa